thank you so much for wanting to talk to
me about mainstream i'm so happy to be
here
oh my gosh no this is fantastic what a
good movie andrew garfield
whoa he i know he just i can't believe
how much he transformed for this film
what was that like working with them
well you know i think it was a it was
definitely like a
role very far away from him you know
he's like uh he's a very modest and like
humble and hard-working human being um
whose morals are really like right in
place
um but i think so i think it was a a big
um you know i mean he'd have to speak
for himself but i think it was a big
stretch and
a lot of work and a lot of dedication
and and commitment to trying to think
about the world differently and imagine
it and see it with new eyes and
you know he just did such a beautiful
job now you guys were so good together
in this the chemistry was just so
fantastic
um what do you think about this
generation
and and our obsession with youtube stars
like in this film
i well i'll say this
i don't have my little sister um
uh has a real obsession with youtube and
youtube stars and like
makeup tutorials and like videos of kids
playing you know like kids are doing
this thing these days or they watch
videos of other kids playing with things
um and it's been really interesting
because the pandemic has
made our relationship to it as like the
adults
in kids lives really different because
i don't know watching videos of kids
playing might be better than not playing
with any kids at all
but also it might not be maybe playing
by yourself is better i
i don't know i um
i find it a really confusing uh topic
because i have all of my feelings about
social media
and i have all of my um ways i use it
and those things don't always intersect
you know it's like
i can talk about how much i don't think
you know instagram is good for girls or
how much i think that
there's a lot of like um you know a lot
of
things that get talked about um don't
actually change in the world
you know um and uh and then i can also
tell you like how i use instagram and
like the pages that i look at and the
profiles that i do and
the way i use it for my own self
promotion and and so it always feels
wrong
to speak against something that is
helping you
um in some way or another or that you
yourself are using you know
it's like um but i also think you know
it's like smoking a cigarette and being
like this is gonna
kill you like you know it's like you
know you got to do it or not do it i
i i guess and um so it's just a
complicated issue
that i think deserves a lot more thought
by a lot of people
a lot smarter than me and two of those
people are tom and gia
um who wrote this movie uh and and and
direct ngo who directed it
and the way in which they use the movie
to explore both of those issues you know
like
andrew's character starts off being like
i hate technology
like phones are the worst i don't have
one i don't want one um and
then by the end of the film he has
like his ego has been so inflated by
technology that he no longer even sees a
difference really between the version of
himself that is
on camera and the version of him that
exists in the real world
um or he's losing that line um and i
think we're all losing that line
um and i don't know i'm gonna stop
rambling
but but no no that's such a good answer
because it it's
it's a hard thing to talk about i mean
there's some wonderful things about
social media and then there's
some really negative things about it as
well
and yeah and and who's watching versus
you know if you're a young kid growing
up versus if you're in your 30s watching
you know
there's just it's it affects people in
very different ways um
you know this movie really highlights
the pressures that come with
kind of reaching that celebrity status
you obviously are young hollywood star
you're in one of the most popular shows
ever
can you relate to the pressures that
this film kind of focuses on
[Music]
yeah i mean i think that what i relate
to is how quickly you lose your compass
like i remember when i first
started when i first left drama school
and started working professionally
i was so optimistic i mean
i was i mean i was working with um a
wonderful actress willie fitzgerald
who's now a really good friend of mine
but who had been working for many many
years
and we would have these conversations
and i would be like
no anything is possible like it's all
about the art like you don't know like
we're all like
um and and she would agree with me but
be like it's so much harder out there
than you think it is
um and i was like it's all about your
outlook and then
i worked for a couple years and i was
like oh it's not all about your outlook
because the pressures of the world and
what the world tells you is important
so quickly infiltrates your imagination
of what is important
um you know i mean i remember on my
first
calls that i would take about like or
like negotiating my contract
i'd be like i don't care i'll do it for
free like
i don't care how big my trailer is why
are you even talking to me about this
like
i don't care about billing why are you
even talking to me about this
and then you do like 10 movies and
you're like huh you know be nice if i
had a bigger trailer
and then you're like on the phone and
you're like if i don't have a trailer as
big as cammy
quats her face like i'm not doing the
movie um
and um of course like those words have
actually never left me out
but um but still like that energy does
perpetuate itself within you um yeah and
and the weight of what the world thinks
is important which is generally fame
money
beauty um uh like
viewership content like the weight of
um making like you know making people
laugh um
uh like people being sexy or hot like
you know just the weight of that
can really start to encroach on even the
most liberated mind
um and uh not that i was ever the most
liberated mind i i in no way was
um you know i i've been in this industry
my whole life to a certain extent um
but i think what mainstream is about is
it is watching that
energy encroach on a really liberated
free mind
yeah you know and uh and and seeing even
how
how it can take that person now no i
agree um and just to wrap things up
obviously you seem like a very close
relationship with both of your parents
who is the bigger
stranger things fan your mom or your dad
who asks for more spoilers
nobody asked for spoilers that's good
the boundaries of my netflix contract
and i never break my netflix contract
i am a tightly closed lid um
you know they're both pretty big fans of
me um and they were pretty big fans of
stranger things before the show came out
and so
i i couldn't pick one because it all
gets all muddled and
and mixed up and and happy but you know
everyone
everyone likes to get on the couch and
and binge the season when uh when it
comes out
awesome well i can't wait for the new
season loved you in this film thank you
so much for your
your great answers you're so insightful
oh geez
well yeah you know doing my best now
you're doing great
and you're uh yeah ponytail yeah
well thanks so much so nice getting
talked to you can't we talk to you for
your next film
oh well if if i ever make one you will
hear about it
you will okay see ya
you